c'est un peu dur matière j'ai pas été au
match avec quoi je vais aller au badge
avec les purger sur la tête valeo match
non mais je comprends pas bougé il a dit
on va plus le mettre dans l'écrivain qui
lie bouquet avec trois mois j'ai pas tu
m'a même pas demandé le résultat du
match
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont fait
match nul 0 à 0 et à la mi temps
ben quoi
robert robert c'est vrai que c'est mon
ami oh bien sûr je suis ton ami tu ne
s'est pas séparé force le répète tous
les jours et bien sûr qu'il est c'est
vrai que c'est mon frère
et comme je suis ton frère bien sûr je
suis ton frère tu stream a marqué sur un
papier je suis ton frère wallon dans ces
conditions est ce que tu es capable de
garder un secret un secret entre nous
c'est la moindre des choses dans l'écho
si tu me dis que c'est un secret si tu
me dis que c'est un secret tu sais ce
que moi je suis un tango tu sais ce que
c'est un tombeau je suis un tambour
alors écoute moi oui oui je vais
t'avouer quelque chose oui j'ai besoin
de 500 francs alors je vais te dire
c'est comme si j'avais rien entendu
allez arrête de faire l'idiot a
récemment fait si la vérité qui compte
sur toi moi je t'ai jamais embêté mois
sur des questions d'argent - savait pas
qui m'adresser c'est tout toi tu m'as
fait peur si c'est une adresse que tu
veux ça je peux te la donner il daterait
c'est ce que tu as donné la neige j'ai
compris j'ai compris à quoi on a un ami
on compte sur lui comme ça qu'ils nous
répondent bravo bravo et bien sûr à 500
francs mais ce jugement et surtout où je
vais sortir 500 francs hausse des
sorties autour d'un moment où quoi et
que je t'en supplie ne m'en parle plus
et moi je tends causerait jamais
arrête de pleurer arrête de pleurer je
n'ai pas demandé une fortune millions
j'ai demandé 500 prend 10 600 francs
mais où je vais sortir ou tu veux ma
mort ou quoi
j'ai des frais et des dépenses des
charges des pacs des cotisants et que tu
t'en supplie sera gentil ne manque aux
plus et moi j'y ferai plus allusion
voilà on est comme ça coûte moins robert
j'ai jamais insisté mois pour les
questions d'argent et que si en train de
faire là n ont jamais insisté mais moi
je te dis une chose
écoute moi bien calmement si tu me les
prêtres et 500 francs tu ne perdra rien
voilà moi je t'annonce moi ma parole
d'honneur
tu me les prêtes dans un mois je te rend
le double de quoi de quoi attends
attends tu m'as dit que tu m'as dit que
si par hasard j'avais 500 francs que les
praticiens asa supposant un droit tu me
rends à la fin du mois tu me rendes
mille francs voilà ça y comprend rien
c'est exactement ça écoute tu sais
justement je sais pas comment je vais
faire un justement j'ai 500 francs sur
moi mais c'est pas un match devenait
rendent à kuito pas soulever le rideau
elle est chaud mais non c'est la vérité
je lui dois mais je ne sais pas qu'est
ce que je lui racontais je vais te le
traité mais tu le dis rien tu dis rien
comme ça la fin du mois tu me rends dans
les mois seulement vrai tous les mois et
après on verra un grand milan à fin du
mois mais c'est pour toi mais moi j'ai
une parole de m
mais attends attends attends j'ai
quelque chose de mieux à trois projets
enrico il reprend 6 500 francs comme ça
la fin du mois du monde devra plus que
ces montants servent à rien